die foto's colors this is to the papers
wit gift journée fire sixth latest
explosion in a year research virtually
no field of science remains number
spanjolet works
these are amazing tools that helps of
problems
where the solochain would be easy to identify
with difficult to explain for instance
wie  low back flip a mission of the
mathematical in the family of three quarters
forces rotations and torque is much more
challenging nu al networks xl at the
skies of test provided that we can still
i'm a large number of training samples
of two peak in site disney  euro
networks with a more and more layers and
more and more neurons within the layers
is hier scopa de final decision
is going to be
bottles number is specially troublesome
in the network use as from cancer
dat wie i do not have access to any sort
of explanation mee  euro niazi eksept we
dat eager consideration this piece
of work' is debate distillation which
means i know and jool at work and
tried to express something in a working in
the form of a decision tree decision
tree is take into consideration the
series of variables and  provide a
gland roadmap to the decisions based on
their for an intern useful in using
the age and the month of real time of
people to try to get further than likely
to play video games or this
finding  location and inca yes
this sounds great hall over the main
issue is that decision tree is a wet
[ __ ] substitute for nuon adwords the
series 6 that we have generation versus
interprata buttocks tea tree day situation
which means that she is that providers
[ __ ] decisions about finding training  dna
and generalized pulley and the warmest where
easy to interpret marina shirt will be in
order to break out of this tradle
situation and
via ideal of this piece of art is  the
first your network to build a decision
tree by taking an input doen set for
training
tryin to generate more training day dag
de fellows so een prak
peace and 4 all this to the the season 3
gerard families as for the testicle
problem of identifying widgets in  die
him die stone set and each season is
meant to cut the number of output options
in half and shows en oriole that we
can vary effective member perform the
classification and only for decisions
of migraines input and not only daad
maar dit also shows where this is  looking
for
for a stans here we go see the
final decision before weekend shift
be input numbers week or eat it
looks for the presence of a tiny er yes
de joins the end of this week to my
knees and different visualization of the
qonect for game betters  argues that in
your network weekly tries to distinguish
your haircut strategies one where the player
starts committing the inner and one of the
operation of the board
this is such let the  streets perform
better than traditional decision tree
what's more the only slightly worse than
the corresponding euro net worth
what can explain their decisions much
more clearly and where oro faster in
summary the rate of progress in machine
learning research is sloerie insane
these days and i'm  all for piepers dutch
writer providers and greater
understanding of what is happening kan
door de hut i'm loving this idea in
particular
we had earlier episode
Houten supercharge the decision tree wirefree
boosting is there interested in learning
more about it the link is available in de
video description tag for watching god'
folio generous support must see you next
time